is campaigning hard with just days
before the final round of France's
parliamentary election he says there's
no time to waste
an activist and candidate for France's
new left-wing Alliance in the
southwestern city of Limoges he's trying
to Rally support in an area where many
people abstained in the first round
because they're Fed Up of politicians
but he says he'll be different
I come from here and I want to see MPS
that actually represent Ordinary People
because that's not been the case for
five years there is this hope that we
finally have a real opposition to macron
and that we can do something new on
issues like climate change
more days leading the race in this
constituency if he wins he will oust the
incumbent an MP with President Emmanuel
macron's party a final round runoff
between candidates from the new
left-wing Alliance and macro Centris
block is taking place in nearly half of
France's parliamentary constituencies
and could upset the president's chances
of obtaining the absolute majority he
needs to push through with his agenda
with things looking uncertain macro made
a rare appeal to voters this week
majority to ensure stability both
outside and inside our borders nothing
could be worse than to add chaos in
France to the chaos in the world
concern over climate change health and
inflation has fueled momentum for the
leftist block at Limoges historical Food
Market the cost of living is never far
from people's minds
people's salaries haven't changed but
everything is going up by five percent
or even more for fuel people worry about
the future about getting to the end of
the month with costs going up people ask
us if we're going to put our prices up
says that if elected he would focus on
improving health services and work to
help people who struggle financially so
far the left and centrists on neck and
neck in terms of votes nationally but
it's estimated that macros Alliance will
win most seats the numbers may be hard
to predict but those here hope that
times are changing
Natasha Butler Al Jazeera Limoges France